[Music]
in quick to judge news that's me all day
always I always will judge very good I
love to judge imma gather the facts type
of guy are you before especially for
post on social media no that's the right
thing to do but it doesn't make life
that funny in Joe or like Cowboys in the
Old West we [ __ ] shoot first and then
we're like oh [ __ ] my bad Steve thinks
everything's a scam right off the bat
yeah hold on skepticism is a great way
to start off cuz then you never know
what is war and you're never like you
know you jump in too hard people I mean
when you thought this was very like and
I know cuz reason is like the right
thing to do right the reasons not fun
coming to conclusions is so fun that can
start with the conclusion no no I know
but then I usually walk it back from
there right it's like how I usually get
a inch but I'm confident ly wrong yeah
but then I find out how wrong I was
later but I was still and it's annoyed
to everybody that was right it's really
Bailey someone cooked you off on the
freeway and you go I bet you you're
Chinese and you drive up you're like oh
[ __ ] it's a white guy yeah that's
different it's a great surprise
submitted by Japanese breakfast oh yeah
rice and miso soup and miso soup for
breakfast oh yeah when I was in Hawaii
there was miso soup at the buffet yeah
there's a lot of Japanese people in
Hawaii yes it's like mostly Japanese yes
you have their own tour bus and
everything jealous cuz I want to jump on
there like no you have to be Japanese
why race they have the biggest
population of Japanese Americans who are
looks like a million or some [ __ ] er
there's like a lot you know why yeah the
most you outside of the mail or Zil no
no no as you as Americans Americans yeah
yeah yeah I was born in Singapore and I
ordered the breakfast because I wanted
to try the Asian breakfast thing and it
was rice soup it was intended soft had a
head pork in it like pork Oh grind up
ground up dried up pork oh yeah and I
was like what there's meat in this like
why what the [ __ ] I just wanted some
oatmeal like I wanted
oh wait in Singapore no no no this all
you're thinking Malaysia I am thinking
Malaysia what I was actually China
Airlines to me oh yeah was China so yeah
I'm gonna judge Japanese breakfast now
or Chinese breakfast now based on a bad
experience that's how I judge [ __ ]
actress Ariel winter got a ton of hate
online after asking fans to contribute
to her cousin's GoFundMe ok she's rich I
bet they're like you're rich [ __ ] you
shouldn't oh the daughter yeah yeah
she's the younger ones they do for mayor
we chose his daughter on the show yeah
on the show yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll
Bundy there were children so she posted
a bit broken heart this is my cousin t
know if you can please consider donating
to his recovery fund anything helps I
love him so much and so what happened to
her cousin was a he contracted this
bacteria that can cause a serious number
of illnesses like meningitis and other
things pneumonia and this other one that
I can't pronounce and so she was asking
for people to to donate and then so she
started posting photos of her with him
he didn't have good probiotics maybe
didn't need kimchi and then people
started responding no offense but like
you obviously that's how I read so miss
my wife obviously had the money if not
all of some of it to help your cousin so
why are you asking your friends for the
money
they're not even Hispanic it's Rebecca
the way that she pointed it know what
fins but like you I literally every girl
in El Paso talks like that
I like starting with no offense and then
you say the most offensive [ __ ] yeah
no offense but like obviously you have
like money novel Talladega Nights River
werewolf I was like well I said no
disrespect like but you said this is
people stuff but but I said no why do
people think all celebrities have money
don't you know that they're broke [ __ ]
no tax they have to give it to their
lawyers they have to give it to their
manager their agents by the time they
get a check it a lot like already
percent of what this oh yes what guys
they're not working at [ __ ] Denny's
okay that's that's what these guys are
saying I'll see the unemployed when the
show gets cancelled like when they're
there when they have to go between jobs
one family got like ten and a half she's
rich no she's rich as [ __ ] she's not
just faking general general yeah go hard
on that [ __ ] come on this chick is
dunking hundreds of thousands in episode
I don't know about you know syndication
yes Auto about her but I know a lot of
artists blow the [ __ ] out of their money
so they typically are in debt so they're
in a worse situation or they blow then
people that work at Denny's sometimes
because they owe millions of dollars and
they're not making as much anymore what
I wish and that's why Dave Coulier
doesn't tip well but but what I wish is
that these guys would be like yo smart
family's not doing that good like we're
on every airline to justify yeah exactly
you got to tell me why you got to walk
it back and tell me why so before we're
tweeting out here like well according to
Forbes you made a hundred thousand every
other yep that's it I'm actually
surprised that they didn't make more
than that per episode I am to her [ __ ]
her agent her baby enough for like what
over 20 thank you like a million million
she's not the highest-paid on is there
like II don't know ed o'neill and in
sofia vergara they probably are catching
i guarantee well like friends when he
was a million in episode back in the 90s
so like today money like that should be
at least a million in episode but that's
not like an ensemble castle when they're
like with 15 people in that show certain
maybe there's not much as much money to
go right no there's
there's money there's their fine I know
for her the money's gonna get so Hamburg
are will give you two million episodes
well they're like hey we can recast you
and nobody will even now branch that's
true cuz I didn't know who she was I
don't know I don't watch the show though
responding with this OH celebrity clap
back dr. Reid I don't usually curse but
thanks for your response to my sick
cousin what makes you think I'm not
loved assumptions by the way if someone
isn't able to donate then I absolutely
wouldn't want them to his friend created
the GoFundMe
so of course I'll share for my cousin
like anyone else would but how much is
they trying to raise $15,000 this
morning oh this is outrageous this chick
should be kicked off a [ __ ] Twitter
kidding me bro she has enough to put a
dent in it maybe she doesn't pay for it
all she got a grand she got five she's
like I can't sell my Netflix
subscription and gave that money to it
this month you [ __ ] kidding me
come on a Burger King that's morning
also said that my family will continue
doing everything we can for him which
shouldn't even be a question outside of
GoFundMe aswell criticizing someone want
a family members ill no you had 15 G's
Ariel winter she's a child too though
what no she's not a child another child
okay especially when somebody has no
idea what's happening I realize well how
about that you have more than 15 grand
in a few minutes un-fuckin'-believable I
like I like the the Twitter handle go
cheap Vegas real windy real windy he's
like a [ __ ] travel it will Twitter
due date he's got to go cheap in Vegas
so he's like how dare you ask me for
money I need every dime and then she
said I am shocked at how many people
have sent me hate tweet people that
grossly overpaid she's underpaid I
invested showing him some love and
support nothing else needed to be done
aside from that I reposted a GoFundMe
that my cousin's friend made just as
anyone else would yeah but your
celebrity you can't just do that when
you are not just anyone exactly it's not
like me
I'm broke my cousin amen let's chip in
you are more than likely a millionaire
or you make hundred thousand dollars
every year you are not anyone else if my
cousin if my own [ __ ] cousin was like
oh I'm going through this medical thing
oh how much does it cost fifteen
thousand well you would know ask your
$15,000 yeah I make a hundred thousand
and episode was it or episode Millions
come on that's it fifteen thousand is
like $20.00 to her yes I would easily
been like no don't make this public
no it's interesting too so her co-star
on her family her name is Sarah Hyland
yeah Sarah Hyland other one that this
chick oh that's about to go she also
tweeted out a GoFundMe page for her
cousins or her fourteen-year-old
cousin's funeral expenses people are
like why why aren't is it a $200,000
funeral like she was also asking for
fifteen thousand dude Niners are so
[ __ ] cheap man
is it or not her but like her family is
another PR move till I pay for it and
then tweet out hey I just paid my
cousin's cost or just shut up and be
rich just handle your own business we
stay four for four don't nobody care
there are people without rich family
members that need to go fund me yeah go
lobbyist for broke to a line and be like
hey man
when your cousin gets sick I'll chip
yeah it's not for celebrities to be like
oh yeah y'all paid we already broke
GoFundMe exactly go funny gives poor
people the opportunity to not do stupid
[ __ ] like car washes and fundraisers
that's all it is we don't have to
[ __ ] lower ourselves we could just
ask politely ask around
yeah where you can fundraise for your
car wash for your fundraiser but you
just don't get that much reach GoFundMe
it's like having a neighborhood where
everyone sheeps chips in but it's a big
neighborhood yes
you're not in our neighborhood I hear we
same but stop defending her
I just see the clapping moment just show
chequered yeah
someone tweeted at Sara saying that she
only donated a thousand while she's
worth nine million unreal bro
what if she's worth nine million but she
doesn't have any cash in her bank
account dude if she said that though
she's like listen I'm a [ __ ] gambling
addict I'm a degenerate gambling addict
here yeah that'd be tired because Mama's
backlash she tweeted you guys finally
did it you're horrible negative ignorant
words have broken me happy question mark
staying offline for a while hobbies I
have a special announcement and video
releasing on Wednesday I had I believe
so there's that Oh dunno if we broke her
it would be like I paid the whole thing
myself
what's announcement she's like I'm
staying off except for this very special
announcement that I must make cuz I'm
gonna drop an album like I gave an extra
$250 new song who's managing these peace
a musician but she's using this as an
opportunity in her bio you know why it's
not a business expense for them so
that's why they're not doing it pain is
not gonna stop there can't be a dis
business expense because it's a donation
I usually think that PR people are a
waste of money but for people like this
that made people who don't have self
awareness they need that absol
everything yes but then all the fun
would be gone right true she thought she
was such a good person for retweeting a
girl cousins go fun that's the best
thing about the internet welcome to
America 2019 dude were there's literally
charity stuff we've been to those things
before yeah well it's like everyone in
retweets this will give a dollar and a
[ __ ] whatever charity it is and then
people like I just did so much charity I
and I signed up five new accounts and
retweeted from those you imagine her
retweeting man coming back hours later
let me let me see what the people gave
me yeah shut up we hate you
Oh cousin out here what happened we
broke out here should I whoa what I did
there's actually less money to go from
you good you got it do I hope her cousin
like wasn't in real serious danger or
anything
Oh Ariel winters cause both of their
cousins
Sarah's cousin was killed by a drunk
driver he was 14 years old Oaks now Owen
said she not feel bad yeah but then uh
Ariel's cousin he has some sort of
bacteria if he at least he doesn't have
like a liver or something that needs
wasn't either way no whatever way like
what like they can just pay the 15 grand
but that's what I'm saying his own
cousin
it's like hey I need a new liver and
then her cousins like here's $100 you
know I'm saying like Oh at least it's
not [ __ ] life-threatening yeah Jesus
so nobody can't be a part of the
GoFundMe community know you can only put
money in and be quiet
you cannot solicit more GoFundMe you
need to be rich or you get to
participate right you can't but what
about Zach Braff funding his new movie
what do you think of that [ __ ] well
you'd like Kickstarter yeah you know
Spike Lee do that - I think kickstart is
different that's different
they're getting a project out of it
they're a fan of your fan of that
person's work so you're contributing to
see more of their work that's what I was
gonna say any good businessman will use
somebody else's money for investment
well a lot of people use GoFundMe as a
means to like get non profit things
going or like Nora like we're like you
know like hospital or like health care
for sure or like buy me a car [ __ ] like
that you know yes I wonder how many is
like 15 year-old kids like buy me a car
I'm gonna go from Yankee fine that [ __ ]
happens yeah I get the end of time from
kids wanting a new computer they're like
can you contribute to my computer fund
I'll go fund me I'm like I need a new
computer getting my cootie I get emails
okay look I get emails of people saying
like I want to go on a Mexico trip with
my friends because I deserve it I just
don't think I deserve a vacation but
they don't have the money for it dude
there is there you are also allowed to
work and save your money
yeah like you deserve it
of course you do okay okay work yeah but
what if I need these fortnight skins and
they're only available this weekend
what do you see see what I'm saying
Kevin you don't really think about the
people who are going through this [ __ ]
that's what it's your night skins are
only available till the fifth and then
it's over so what are you gonna do about
that keV I'll pay you back later yeah
and he doesn't get paid until weeks
later